welcome to this video with zikomo tom
yeah playing this guy quite often don't
really remember have a good score but it
don't remember any particular games is
he playing she playing the London system
do I remember that right no i don't ok
is so I ago I probably had some bogus
against them maybe may your for Queens
engine just try something else let's see
maybe Jack kind of mixing ideas here ok
let's just play a very very simple
fashion for once hmm some people
recently played this against me with
wide I mean me being wide and I had
absolutely nothing so I'm going to try
that it wasn't super exciting for black
but it felt like super solid I like a
closed Catalan where the black Bishop is
traded which is quite nice actually to
have this traded gives black some needed
space often we you get a good square on
e 7 for the Queen now sometimes in those
positions you don't know where to put
the Queen and here this is a good square
ok I didn't play Queen see tune ok so
how to play do I go be five in this
position or us play for c5 hmm
c5 looks loose but yes efore in the in
the making b5 cb5 mmm that looks kind of
awkward
I'm not really sure about that tricky c5
looked bad but rook c84 also hmm i don't
know if i go here bear b5 what is he
doing you can play c5 then i go before
having this bishop at least a bit
activated no the problem might be that
my poor near before and later a five can
can become weak after a four for example
i will take and then the a pawn can
become might become weak
at least this is fairly fairly solid
it's not a position to break down easily
i hope but this is one of those mornings
moments by you're probably initiating a
very quick loss not like my position is
sound and then it's like bang bang
resins and thank you okay he goes he
form I wonder how should I take care
pause that difference first of all I
don't know figure that out it takes
probably too much time k yeah at least
this is a good square but why it has
asked hazards a good squares as well 95
this kind of business yeah quickly
played not sure though a five there's
also a form and I don't like that the
rather take em hmm really what do you
want to trade my bishop here
hmm mmm can I somehow keep the pawn I
know it's kind of greedy but term
it's drawn for that even Queen a5 this
is a move I mean it's a self-penned
which is kind of problematic I
understand
I can check here first let's do that
roop cheeks is not very enticing and
Quinn TX always gives me checking
opportunities between a five yeah 95 is
an idea to try to I can go to be 5 i'm
not quite sure maybe i can do that it's
kind of ambitious 95 493 maybe never ok
i know i'm going to try that trying to
keep this pawn with pawn to a to the
before night is also covering c6
make and I can play Nancy forward this
is this is probably probably probably a
kind of a perpetual I know the 996 I can
go to be eight so okay that's not a
problem good okay remember that one we
never five we can go back so to not draw
I have to have to step back here okay
I'm thinking did that one probably if he
takes i'm going to i'm getting this
activity a little bit of activity then
transferring also the eighth pawn to b4
if he takes and if he I mean if he is
not taking how is he getting the pawn
back t8 maybe
okay okay why not takes Queen takes as
possible
we'll end up with some kind of extra
porn and game
shaking and I can take be three as well
maybe not completely show him what's
best
a good thing is that there is always a
five I mean the du Pont is also a target
five right
okay takes p39 morning let's play the
simple continuation oops I didn't think
that was possible I thought takes d3 but
he's just in time it's just in time
taking this rookie for d3 rook a 1 and D
2 rook v1 yeah it so it's an extra porn
but it's not an easy win what quite
disappointing really now let's check
made what's close to play rook t5 Wow
okay check check check always look for
checkmate checkmate it was handy okay i
was a bit bit ahead on the clock anyway
so wasn't it wasn't a problem okay let's
let's review this a little bit um
somehow this went downhill for white out
of a pretty normal position here white
is definitely a bit better Mookie one
the sword all looks totally normal I'm I
mean a form sree form is not bad
probably but I'm not totally sure that
you need to do it at this precise moment
another good wave to place always going
for this or a three let's say and just
initiate this transformation on the
queenside where the a pawn will always
be some kind of liability I mean
sometimes you can just be okay with III
and just play against upon and this is
this is ok but i'm not sure if you need
to do it right away and this gives me
some some squares as well night if 5k
took yeah until he starts to get
interesting I think he should just take
but he didn't want to and all of a
sudden I get to get to get this kind of
funny complications where I'm keeping
this pawn for a moment comes you down
once to what yeah you know compute the
chess computer suggests rook a to remove
that is very difficult for a human to
come come to yeah kind of tip putting
this on pre not a cabal of course
because of the pin when it's idea assume
do this very nice now it didn't do that
it's a slight edge by the way from a
white if he would have done that and
here I'm just keeping keeping my
material and I'm better with a five now
it's switched to them to the deep on
there are only various weaker weaker
inferior end games that that can come up
maybe I should take III I'm not sure
here I'm not sure here this keeps an
edge but it's kinda tree couldn't really
determine what's what's best yes it's
definitely always always better for
black [ __ ] white of course has drawing
chances to pawn down i probably could
have played them more precisely earlier
okay well thanks for watching